[Music]
if people are aware of dentists and they
realized who he was and they kind of
know what his character was like and it
was really what it was like I mean he
was just a happy guy he always had this
infectious sort of positive attitude
which honestly for a lot of his
teammates probably was a bit far apart a
big factor in them actually achieving
the results that they did he was a very
driven person to get better like every
day he was striving to be a better
person of himself I know that's that's
easily said and I think a lot of people
will say that about themselves but
there's definitely a difference in the
level of some top athletes and Dennis
was absolutely one of them we lost
somebody who was somebody who spread
cheer enjoyed life to the fullest in
many ways and also somebody who would
always be there to talk to you if he
needed to talk and I think we lost
somebody great but I think I think that
is what he was a good leader a really
good one and we lost we lost him I think
he'd achieved what he wanted as a player
and now he wanted to start giving back
and I think the act of giving back and
the importance that that had to him
really drove him to work very hard on on
becoming the kind of person that players
could respect as a coach
[Music]
[Music]
Internet Hulk was a born competitor I
think I'm one of the most driven persons
in East bud business all I have in my
life and is this my life like I only
care about East was and I want to make
it I want to be number one he reached
rank one in World of Warcraft during
season two but it was as a Starcraft 2
streamer that he first started
attracting a following
now I remember connected back from 2010
2009 that it have had a huge community
in stock up and I was part of it
Hulk eventually turned to League of
Legends at the end of season 3 and by
January 2014
Hulk became the first player to ever
reach the Challenger ranked in Europe as
a jungler with the handle RMD axe little
did he know at the time but League of
Legends was only the first step on his
way to eSports superstardom an elite
international task force charged with
ending the war and restoring Liberty to
all nations
overwatch hope didn't waste any time
jumping into overwatch and assembled the
core of the potent iddqd roster during
the early days of the competitive scene
we formed a team and we had another
almost 60 win streak but the game wasn't
as competitive as after release Internet
Hulk was a flex player for the team and
his favorite and most played hero was
Winston a character that allowed him to
make a major impact on the game while
clearing space to allow his teammates to
pop off well one of the reasons I played
him so much so I'm actually really good
at him I feel like and it's just one of
the characters where you can do like a
lot of small things that Deus have such
significance for your team he was known
for his ability to control the pace of
the game set up timely dives and play
any hero that his team needed but the
speed boost out here comes iddqd in Bob
coming out here from internet Hall takes
out two people absolutely beautiful
stuff coming out from him the team
garnered reputation as one of the scenes
most feared at a time when the
competitive overwatch world was largely
ranked by word of mouth
in Europe he had iddqd with Internet
Hulk and a lot of the players that are
on our team still today those guys were
really dominant then in April 2016 that
same roster was signed by envious ahead
of APEC season 1 the first step into the
world of real overwatch eSports
once we signed with mV I heard someone
coming up to me and tell me like dude
I'm so happy I ended up with envious and
there was someone who wanted us for the
organization you said like Mike's one of
the best owners and and that's really
what like has been proven yeah we really
wanted to work with the iddqd team and
have them play with tailspin and that's
held in us and I met like he brought us
over to America as the first team in
Elvidge to bring into a gaming house and
believe in to us with the release of the
games so when Korean Broadcasting
Company odn announced that they'd be
hosting a packs a two month long
tournament with many of the game's most
prolific personalities and rosters the
pilot light for the world's next big
eSport was Laden was the largest
qualifier for any tournament in OGN
history and this goes back all the way
through every single game we're talking
starcraft brood war League of Legends
everything that they've done more people
attempted to get into this tournament
and we're down to the last 12 of those
Korean teams and apex and rounding out
with four teams come coming in from the
international scene in the West and
compete here in Seoul Internet Hulk
captained team Envy squad and played
alongside the likes of tae Moo TaleSpin
chips Heian Harry hook and Coco Palka
stem mastermind kinda off our team he's
kind of like the glue of our team I
would say a little bit of the team
captain he's always you know the one
that's like getting us you know
motivated very serious all the time and
really wants to make it down on us to do
as good as we can headed into the event
they were thought to be one of the
strongest Western teams in the world you
know I thought it was the team with the
most how in the world
with and it was kind of clearly showing
a competition not that we were really
competing with Koreans back then but you
know in terms of the Western world like
there was nobody better than that to
human but Andy you were pretty much
ahead of the pack already in the West at
that time the team made it through to
the bracket stage relatively unscathed
but they were experiencing some internal
issues that resulted in tailspin leaving
the team before the bracket stage we had
one of our players not be able to make
it out to Korea and we had this gaping
hole for another player and we had to
make a playoff push in that first season
of Apex tailspins departure would prompt
Hulk to go out and find a new sixth to
field the lineup for the elimination
stage Denis came to me at the time as
kind of a captain of our team and he
said Mike I met this guy at the World
Cup he plays for Thailand his name is
Mickey he's got this amazing attitude
and he's really skilled and he's a
really great diva player and we really
want to get him put on the team and I
had no idea who he was and Dennis I'll
never forget just said trust me Mike
trust me this is the guy we need he can
be really good and he has an amazing
attitude he's gonna be really good for
our team just trust me
after a middling group stage Hulk knew
that his team would have to kick it up a
notch if they wanted to upset Korea's
best and as it turned out the Thai flex
tank player was exactly the spark of
energy that Envy needed him to be just
like Internet hope promised and Vee
would go on to defeat rogue in the
quarterfinals they will win this match
and go to the semi-finals and Kong do in
the semis are going to the grand finals
which landed them in a grand final
showdown against Africa blue in the end
it was the team first culture that
Internet Hulk fostered that allow
envy to become the first Western eSports
franchise to go to Korea and emerge with
a first-place finish and that is it
envious will win Intel overwatch APEC
season one with a four Oh victory gg Wow
huge win from envious look at these guys
coming through this tournament everybody
thought it was over when tailspin left
that was gonna be as Nikki comes in as
an emergency substitute on to this team
and he helps the team go away to a clean
sweep of a Korean grand final it may
seem small looking back but apex was
everything competitive overwatch had at
the time and internet Hulk's envy Squad
were on top of the world after that
first apex title Hulk would lead NV to
another top eight finish in apex season
two with season two in his rearview and
his 30th birthday quickly approaching
Internet Hulk decided to step away from
playing overwatch competitively in favor
of coaching a job he seemed to fit for
from the start Hulk started his coaching
career with envy but things didn't go as
planned I think he got a little
distracted he certainly started spending
a lot more time
you know networking and wanting to go to
other gaming events and you know wanting
to do all these things that come with
you know being a famous pro gamer and
that didn't translate well when you're
having the transition to be a head coach
of a team every player knew his
capability and if he wasn't gonna use it
his full potential and the head coaches
coaching position then we were better
off with another coach ahead of season 3
Hulk took a role coaching rogues
overwatch team and led them to a nine
and twelve record their new coach of
costs he's in one Champion Hulk coming
by after Blizzard announced the
overwatch League Hulk had moved on to
coach team liquid at overwatch
contenders and led them to a second
place finish I just feel like Team
Liquid always deserves to be right on
the top right on itself they deserve to
have championship teams and I want to
Iowan I want achieve that after that
season
it was revealed that Hulk would be
taking on a different role within the
team liquid organization he'd be heading
back to his League of Legends roots and
become head coach of their LCS team we
hired Dennis to coach with with all
everything in place that that might be
difficult to overcome so just not having
coached League of Legends we believe
that he could do it and that's not
because we underestimate the difficulty
of going from one game to another we
were actually fully we fully recognized
that that is not an easy switch and we
believe that from everything that we had
seen of him
we believed that he could do it Hulk had
lived the professional eSports dream
he'd become a known Starcraft streamer
highly-ranked League of Legends player a
world-class overwatch captain and now a
professional coach but then tragedy
struck on November 8th 2017 Team Liquid
announced that Dennis Internet Hulk a
velka had died
[Music]
we got a call from the owner of Team
Liquid it was a very good friend of mine
Victor and he yeah told me he had some
pretty rough news and went on to explain
to me that they couldn't get ahold of
Dennis for a few days and wasn't normal
and they had to you know break into his
apartment where they found him and he
was gone one of the founding fathers of
overwatch eSports a captain a teammate
and a coach was gone all too soon as the
overwatch community mourn the loss of
one of its founding fathers some of
those closest to Hulk opted to celebrate
his life we lost somebody who was
somebody who spread cheer enjoyed life
to the fullest in many ways and also
somebody who would always be there to
talk to you if he needed to talk and I
think we've lost somebody great he's
been with a lot of teams he was in the
overwatch leagues he will the overwatch
scene since it's very beginning of the
closed beta and he was had this
infectious sort of positive attitude but
I think I think that is what he was a
good leader a really good one and we
lost we lost him many of over watches
most prolific names competed and casted
during the Hulk tastic Cup a testament
to the many lives Hulk touched during
his time as a competitor the tournament
was a benefit for Hulk's family with any
leftover money being donated to charity
I think we also have a message from
Hulk's family I'm gonna I'm gonna try to
read oh yeah to the best I can
we are totally overwhelmed by all the
love and support from the community as
well as the love and the respect towards
our son and brother we start to realize
more and more what he meant to the scene
and why he felt so comfortable
you guys in a hard time right now to
find the right words the only thing we
can truly say is we thank you from the
bottom of our hearts
fast forward a few months later and the
overwatch world reached the climax its
followers hoped for when they were
watching Envy lifts the apex trophy for
the first time the overwatch League the
time is now years of dedication months
of sacrifice have all led to this moment
and that envy roster that Hulk poured
his blood sweat and tears into was now
the Dallas fuel one of the most exciting
rosters on paper
heading into season one the excitement
of this new game in mind the community
never forgot about the impact Hulk had
on the development of the game in fact
they immortalized him in the game's
history this award would be presented to
the player who had the most positive
impact on the overwatch community at
large and to announce the winner of our
first ever Dennis ha Velka award it will
be one of his championship teammates
from team envyus the always smiling at
Mickey the emotional core of the Dallas
fuel congratulations Becky if I like
being sad to them like being unhappy and
make anything go worse it's just like
everything gonna be worse so I just
think in a positive way like just like
everything passed just passed make you
thank you for being such a shining
example of positivity and fineness I
know Dennis would be very very proud
that's what she's one of his teammates
to receive this award he brings an
element to the team that every team
needs and I think that's what Dennis saw
in Mickey when he asked me to sign him
and I think that in addition to his
positive impact on the community make
him the best candidate for the Dennis
Pavelka work dead in his word I said is
really mean to me since the reason I am
here because of him
additionally they created a memorial to
Hulk inside the game itself right by the
attacker spawn on Ike involved between
the Hulk tastic Cup I'm in Game Memorial
and this award that celebrated his name
the overwatch community will never
forget Internet Hulk in just 30 years
Internet Hulk lived the kind of life
that many dream about the kind of life
that left a mark on everyone he met well
Dennis was basically just a lodge loud
goofy and happy-go-lucky person there's
someone who was so driven
he was absorbing all information to get
better at what he did nobody I'd
probably have ever met that was more
passionate about you know finding the
right fit for him and his team because
team you what he had at that moment was
what he's been working for for ten years
he's the person that really like means a
lot to me he never stopped was never
satisfied and achieved his wildest
dreams I may be coming out of gaming
when I was 29 I had a rough past before
that but I told my dad what I'm doing
and he's watching my games and it's the
best feeling in the world to actually
make your parents proud and I feel like
that's that's what I did it's amazing
and along the way he made the kind of
mark that can never be forgotten he was
a very driven person to get better like
every day he was striving to be a better
person of himself I know that's that's
easily said and I think a lot of people
will say that about themselves but
there's definitely a difference in a
level of some top athletes and Dennis
was absolutely one of them I think he'd
achieved what he wanted as a player and
now he wanted to start giving back and I
think the act of giving back and the
importance that that had to him really
drove him to work very hard on on
becoming the kind of person that players
could respect as a coach and for that in
eSports and to all those he touched he
will always be a hero
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
heroes never die
you
you
you